so what is this rejection you don't like
being rejected by your friends
especially when you reach out to them
i think the problem is um they
a lot of my friends are
have acting careers
and it's not acting right so it's like
they don't also they're not privy to
the kind of audience that i have and um
it would be a positive thing for their
life i think if they did it
um so they think that it's um
also i have to also say that i've
changed
so it's like people that i met back
25 years ago 20 years ago think that i'm
gonna like make them eat my pubes or
something
right because they think that i'm the
that the bobby lady yeah and it's like
no i i
i've changed
like i'm not as wild
and it's still wild yeah but i'm pretty
tame though i saw an interview on q13
seattle or you're about to do a show at
the parlor and the interview you just
pretty much kept moving to him as close
as possible
sitting on his lap you kissed him
and uh
unless that was 20 years ago i don't
think it was probably 10 years ago and
and also um
i have to say i don't remember that okay
it is something that i probably would do
right but
you have to understand those morning
shows are so god have you you've done
them oh yeah they're so you have to give
them something that i have to do
something
to make it weird
and to to make it awkward
because i don't i'm not in there i'm not
like some of these comics like carlos
mencia or whatever that have just choked
choke choke choke and do his bits stolen
joke joke jokes
that's a funny joke no thanks um
but anyway
let's move on
you don't want to talk about that i
don't
i want i do want to talk about
um how i've changed though
and i think tell me it's because i'm i'm
almost 50.
yeah you're turning 50 next year no in a
couple of weeks okay
are you having a party
i was gonna have one right but um i know
that you had a birthday dinner didn't
invite me but my point is is that um i
had 15 people come over and you you're
too busy for me you're true
you're famous now if you threw out a
line that would have been suffice
you would come
if you threw out a line who knows i will
always throw out a line for now and i
didn't want to bother you
i don't think that's what it was i don't
think that i was in your mind i think
you would have had a boring time you
wouldn't know a lot of people and you
feel uncomfortable and i saved you well
i know you're a board game kind of like
let's do charades kind of guy i've been
to your parties well
we can't have those parties nowadays i
know but you're one of those guys let's
get together and play
um
i don't know anything let me think of a
make up a game you were thinking risk
kamachanzi or whatever chansey we put
the blocks on the thing and then we try
to pull it i don't know what it is but
my point is is that
you're that type of guy it's it's like
old-timey 1970s jim henson
party moriarty moriarty party
so you don't want to enjoy me i mean
look at that
yeah there's masks and things that's
number one what kind of mask is that
that's from smallville i wore that in an
episode but is that not a jim henson
kind of a thing i mean there's some jim
henson puppets up there yeah yeah yeah
it's weird is it weird
it is maybe because you know i
maybe it's a distraction yeah the more
distractions i have in the house the
less i have to deal with me
by the way
i miss you i miss you do you know i was
i hadn't i've had anxiety what's your
problem
you have a vibe i have a vibe yeah yeah
you like his vibe
no it's like almost like he's nervous or
something he's not nervous i'm nervous
everything's fine
okay
no he's like fidgeting and you know he's
writing right what is he writing he's
writing notes he's saying cut this this
is boring yeah all those you're going to
call me no this is great yeah so you're
turning 50.
so you're not going to have a party
you're not going to do anything i was
gonna have a big shindig i was gonna get
a restaurant i was gonna invite as as
many people as i could
but then delta happened delta variance
yeah and it's just like you know
we're still in it
there was many thoughts that i had like
because i got facts and all that stuff
that i was like oh this is the new age
you know this is and it's like no we're
still in it
it's terrible so can't you get some
friends together like me
no i i can't do it because of um
because of kalila
what do you mean you can't do it because
of your wife she i didn't realize you're
married
i don't know married it says online you
were married i know you're married i
know
you do know that's good you know that
do you think we're married i think
you're married i think you got married
in 2016. and you really didn't tell
people
we are married yeah
anyway um let's talk about us
you